bonjour alexis est heureuse de bonjour
dès lors cette matinale berthet france
alors il ya la polémique sur le maintien
des masques à l'école pour l'instant les
mesures qu vide qui se succèdent et
toujours une difficulté à comprendre en
tout cas les mesures sanitaires de la
part des français oui parce que ces
mesures sanitaires elles évoluent elles
changent mais surtout on a l'impression
que c'est un jeu on ne comprend plus en
fait les choix de l'exécutif dans la
façon de maltraiter des français pour
leur bien pour les protéger on a vu ces
derniers jours des parents d'élèves se
lever contre l'obligation du masque à
l'école pour les plus jeunes qui
porterait plus de huit heures 10 heures
par jour le masque y compris dans les
cours de récréation alors cette semaine
à rendez-vous est prévu pour alléger le
protocole à l'école après les vacances
scolaires les tests également auto test
des enfants qui étaient intenables pour
la plupart des familles donc tout ça va
changer il serait temps et puis la
question bien sûr de une infection égale
une injection d'olivier veyrat qui est
un aveu d'échec finalement puisque les
français ont boudé la troisième dose
imposé pour conserver son pass vaccinale
et ne pas être désactivé et on voit bien
que rétropédale ans le ministre pour ne
pas perdre la face a finalement décrété
que mais après tout si vous avez au
micro ça vaut bien une piqûre et vous
garderez votre place mais si vous n'avez
pas fait de piqûres auparavant vous
n'aurez pas de passe bref beaucoup de
vidéos comiques qui circulent à ce sujet
sur internet parce que les français en
ont marre comme la plupart des européens
ça fait deux ans que ce cirque dur et on
voit bien que il n'ya plus rien de
sanitaires là dedans finalement à part
avoir rendu les gens heureux inquiet de
montrer leur cuiller code de manière
perpétuelle ou de le perdre au grand
malheur si jamais il refusait une
injection dieu merci olivier ferrand
dans une
grand geste d'amitié a décidé de rendre
possible de conserver son pass après
seulement deux doses oui et à cela
s'ajoute le coût pour les finances
publiques de la gestion de la crise
sanitaire avec le recours important on
l'a dit on au cabinet de conseil est ce
que c'est justifié oui alors c'est
vraiment là que le bât blesse
26,8 millions d'euros dépensés par le
ministère de la santé pour le cabinet
mckinsey et il ya d'autres cabinets de
conseil à la facture s'élèverait à
plusieurs millions pour pourquoi pour
des conseils des conseils d'ingénierie
sociale pour par exemple inventé ce pass
sanitaires pour travailler sur la
vaccination des enfants dès le mois de
janvier un nouveau contrat a été signé
avec mckinsey pour justement inciter à
la vaccination des enfants et quand on
demande aux libéraux mais à quoi servait
tous ses contrats il lui dit mais vous
savez on n'avait pas les moyens de
travailler donc on a dû faire un recours
massif au cabinet de conseil le problème
c'est que ces cabinets de conseil sont
des entreprises privées souvent
étrangère et qui ont accès aux données
de l'état français ou données de santé
des français qui peuvent finalement tout
savoir de nous et qui conseille le
gouvernement qui final on obéit à des
invectives et mckeen's est comme tous
les autres cabinets de conseils sont
aussi pieds et poings liés avec le
sommet économique le forum économique
mondial de davos c'est eux qui écrivent
ce grétry 7,1 de klaus schwab donc en
fait il conseille également l'entreprise
pharmaceutique mc kids est par exemple
est un des cabinets de conseils les plus
réputés dans le secteur pharmaceutique
or certains cadres de sanofi autres
disaient vous savez mckinsey ça coûte
très cher généralement les rapports
servent à créer les rapports d'après
donc c'est un système qui s'auto
entretient donc quand l'état tombent
dans le piège du cabinet de conseil il
n'en sort plus et qu'est ce que ça dit
ça dit un manque de moyens crucial à un
manque de compétences également à quoi
sert olivier ferrand pourquoi une
payons-nous olivier van avec nos impôts
en plus de pays avec nos impôts des
cabinets de conseil et puis payer 26 8
millions d'euros ma qu'ils aient pour
qu'ils emmerdent les français avec le
pass vaccinale et que ça dure comme ça
pendant deux ans je crois que c'est pas
de l'argent forcément bien dépensé il ya
un conseil scientifique en plus mais bon
et la plupart des rapport de mckinsey
fonds au conseil scientifique bien sûr
c'est sur ces rapports là que ça pue le
conseil scientifique pour ensuite fermer
ouvrir décrété déconfinement
s'attaquer aux non vaccinés bref il ya
une vraie faillite la du gouvernement
ailleurs en europe en tout cas les les
pays certains pays abandonnent les
mesures de privation et de liberté et
l'epasa unitaire en tout genre mais pas
encore en france pourquoi
bonne question c'est vrai qu'on voit
partout un mouvement populaire au canada
le convoi de la liberté alors ça fait
peur à ces gouvernements asseyant guy
leader qui sortent eux aussi du world
economic forum qui se rendent compte que
le plan l'idée de faire la même chose
dans tous les pays avec justement l'aide
des cabinets de conseils pour faire que
les procès soient les mêmes que la
sortie de crise soit à peu près tout le
temps la même que la vaccination soit
partout la même ça ne marche pas deux
ans après les populations sont fatiguées
elles sont surtout excédé de voir
l'inanité des politiques publiques de
voir aussi qu'il n'ya plus rien de
sanitaires aujourd'hui alors que la
vague au micron baisse alors que on a pu
à faire une épidémie de non vaccinés
vacciner comme non vaccinés sont
porteurs du virus certains se retrouvent
aussi à l'hôpital avec des formes
sévères donc il ya là un vrai problème
de fond sur la façon dont les
gouvernements ont géré de manière
coercitive le contrôle des populations
et ça craque de partout vous avez montré
dans un sujet précédent en espagne aux
pays bas des marches tout le temps en
france évidemment tous les samedis et
partout le même message laissez nous
vivre on ne peut plus continuer à vivre
sous un règne communiste qui empêche
finalement de ville sachant que
maintenant nous avons des traitements
des vaccins et des hôpitaux qui s'il
craque ce n'est pas la faute du coc vie
d'un perpignan un hôpital de campagne
vient d'être montée pourquoi parce qu'on
manque de bras on manque de lits tout
simplement et ce n'est pas le coc vide
qui fait qu'on manque de soignants à
l'hôpital public merci beaucoup c'était
l'édito politique d'alexis poulain ce
matin dans la matinale